أنا عصفور أنا عصفور
بيتي من قش مضفور
أفراخي تلعب و تدور تكبر وترفرف بسرور
أناعصفور أنا عصفور عصفور  أنا عصفور
أحضر قشة تلو القشة أجمعها كي أبني عشا
أتخيرها عودا عودا وكأنى سأشيد عرشا
فى صبر بين الأغصان أنسج عشي بإتقان
أناعصفور أنا عصفور  أنا أنا  أنا أنا عصفور
أنا عصفور أنا عصفور
بيتي من قش مضفور
أفراخي تلعب و تدور تكبر وترفرف بسرور
أناعصفور أنا عصفور عصفور  أنا عصفور
هيا أخبرنا يا عصفور لتعلمنا وأنت صغير
لكن حقا بمهاراتك كم تبهرنا يا عصفور
أرقد ساعات ساعات في صبر أرعى بيضات
تفقس تفقس تشيك تشيك أطعمها بعض الحبات
أنا عصفور أنا عصفور بيتي من قش مضفور
أفراخي تلعب و تدور تكبر وترفرف بسرور
أناعصفور أنا عصفور عصفور  أنا عصفور
من عش قش دافئ وصغير سأعلمها كيف تطير
كيف ترفرف بجناحيها فالأفق جميل وخطير
أبني عشي يا أطفال وحدي في كل الأحوال
بيتي لصغاري يكفيني فيه الود وراحة البال
أناعصفور أنا عصفور عصفور  أنا عصفور